Truly, truly, truly.
I think this is why a lot of kids grow up with so many issues.
And they fucking hate their mom,
hate their dad.
They're just like,
fuck everything.
And I feel like this is why the world is going to shit,
because so many women,
they leave their marriage.
And instead of saying,
I already tried that,
I raised these kids thus far as a family. Mommy,
daddy, everybody.
That shit didn't work.
I'm not gonna try to replicate it.
I'm not gonna try to recreate the fucking wheel.
The shit didn't work.
I'm not gonna bring more adults into their life
to tell them what to do,
to have some say in their life
that god only knows if that's gonna fucking work out.
Spend all those years submitting to a fucking stepfather.
Okay, okay.
And I'm like, well,
he said so, so,
you know, we gotta compromise,
go through all that,
and then the relationship doesn't work out.
And then the kids grow up and they're like, mom,
I really wish it would have just been you and the other parent,
not all these extra steps and this and bonus that.
So the way it works is the house is big enough that all of us fit,
and then there's a bunch of extra space where he's got his space.
So when I'm with my kids, doing what I gotta do with my kids,
he's doing his own thing.
When we're all ready to Hang out and I'll be together.
We all hang out and we be together.
And then when it's time for the kids to be with their dad,
they go with their dad, and it's just me and him.
It's a beautiful little living arrangement
that doesn't force anybody into anything they're uncomfortable with.